so
okay hello everyone
welcome to a design review related to
sports language version 13.1
and we are looking at
things about the styling of
uh geometric scenes now i have a
question oh gosh this that thumb there
we have to put it there right because
because we're bringing this thing up
underneath it right
no that's what you can resize i i know i
understand i understand it so you can
resize but i'm saying that it isn't
flush with the bot i mean this is this
needs a tiny graphic design tweak this
isn't right it just looks crazy it looks
like a lost
there if if we could see if we can get
jeremy maybe he will have an immediate
idea about how to do this
yeah i don't think i've noticed that
before is that a
change i just missed it
that's been there for a while um
i'm sorry can just structure it who's
pm'ing here
dorothy
dorothy evans is p.m
okay so could you try and get hold of
jeremy i will try to get a hold of
jeremy thanks
um
okay
all right let's start off here
um oh that's cool to be able to use
pattern filling that's really cool
so i mean if i say
hatchfilling here for example
now
why is that hatch filling as i see is
that because the triangle is is
gray um
so the opacity is not one the opacity is
for triangles and discs and whatnot are
uh it's like 0.5 or something so that
you can see lines because frequency they
always other that they
look good
i love that hatch filling stuff that's
really cool
okay so what am i looking at here so
yeah the option for geometric scene
which here's the hypothesis style
basically before this if you wanted to
style things in a geometric scene you
had to
wrap the individual primitives in
style and you know do it for each thing
uh especially for the euclid project it
would
they get a lot cleaner code
um
having options where you can
style at the end of the
at the end of the geometric scene using
an option
i don't understand what part of this is
the hypothesis
the second argument
so hold on this is the
i'm totally confused this is
second argument
hypothesis
okay
right because there's hypothesis and
then there's right so there's the
there's the raw object right the raw
points and quantities then there are
you know the things you're actually
drawing which are the hypotheses and
which which are distinct from the
conclusions right might be the other
might not be there
right so if there's a third
list in there then there will be
conclusions right that's it that's what
what's
what hypothesis style is distinguishing
from right so the the conclusion in that
that example you're looking at now has
the third uh
third argument which is the conclusion
all right let's zoom out a bit let's
think about equational proofs
do they have hypotheses and conclusions
they do don't they
yes you know what i'm saying so
their styling no it's always so i don't
think a
theorem has supposed a conclusion the
proof doesn't
so
if i say a plus b equals b plus a
that's not a proof that's a theory i
know it's a theorem but are you saying
that that has a hypothesis and a
conclusion in it
the hypothesis is like
a is element of this ring or something
like this which is dropped
yeah
okay
and then the conclusion is a plus b
equals b plus a is that right yeah
okay
but
in an equational proof isn't it the case
the things that the top are hypotheses
and things at the bottom are conclusions
i mean in other words those are those
are displayed
in our
modern but i i assume it got in here
that the new find equational proof
coloring and so on
i haven't checked this i don't know
who's project managing that
anybody have any idea
i don't know if it's in the prototype
bill that's certainly not master
ouch
oh don't tell me we goofed this up
i mean
there are there are issues with the
implementation
um
well
just you know nick
just started fixing a bunch of stuff in
here
oh come on
did this get
okay
who is pming in this area
do we have any idea
i will check to see if i can find out
um
i mean i guess technically
avery right find equational proof goes
through ild but
okay well i mean we've got this really
nice new styling for the stuff that we
did
for the mathematics project looks really
good
but if i'm not mistaken
you know these are hypotheses these are
conclusions
well
those are axioms
what's the difference between an axiom
and a hypothesis
um
they're playing kind of the same role
here i think
well but uh an axiom
[Music]
no i mean right there
i mean obviously on some on some level
it's linguistics but also you have
um
right axioms are things that are taken
to be true
and from which you derive other things
whereas hypotheses are sort of things
to be the case
it's really the same thing it's really
the same thing they're both you know one
happens to be a little bit more commonly
thought to be true
like
you know
the power well
i mean no i mean axioms are taken to be
the foundations of the logical system
whereas a hypothesis
is something a statement which you can
prove you know
modulo incompleteness a hypothesis is
something that you can either prove or
disprove
right
the action cannot be formed
i see you're saying hypothesis your
definition of a hypothesis
doesn't say but the hypotheses you've
defined here are of a different kind yes
because they are not kind of statements
right these are hypotheses which just
say
you know it's like in group theory you
can say i'm cons considering the group
s5 or a5 or whatever the heck it is
no it's it's more like let a be an
abelian group
exactly right it's saying
you know
consider the line connecting a b
and the circle that goes through b and c
centered at a
et cetera there might not exist a scene
that precedes what you fly down
yeah okay
hey we have jeremy here and we have a
first question about see that see that
resize thumb
sharing with us
yeah i see him here but i don't hear him
saying anything so jeremy maybe you're
having an audio problem
um
that's weird can you hear me
yes you're very soft but we can hear you
okay you see this resize thumb i do yeah
yeah
do you consider it kind of ugly and it's
float to it it's yes it's really strange
yeah i i wonder what i mean no leading
questions
[Laughter]
it's got to be in that position because
this thing's coming in underneath it
whatever although why that can't that
thing just float below like the other
thing does yeah my first question
presumably the thumb you know the draggy
thing is attached you know as an element
and a pain
right and right i understand
why
you know what that thumbny thing is
doing there but my question is just so
why can't this get outside the frame
yeah right the points thing is outside
the frame so why can't this piece be
outside the frame also
seems sensible to me
anybody is there a semantic reason why
that that thing is outside and this
thing is inside
um
no i think that was just a design
decision okay so we should flip this if
it can be done we should flip this
around and then that thumb can happily
live in the corner
so then is the
thing that's popping in and out
permanently visible
no no i think it would the question
would be it's a mouse over so the
question would be
will mouse over be okay if you mouse
over this and then it bouncing over this
has something show up outside of it
will that disappear when you when you
mouse over that you need to get
yeah i i believe that those are
supported removal conditions for an
attached cell but i you know i'm not i'm
not john so i won't promise that wow and
this creature is hanging out
you know
this tail is hanging over the edge of
the wall so to speak right which is
which is a design feature of attached
cells right if we don't want that
behavior we would need a different
implementation but i'm not sure what
that difference implementation would be
okay but so then in this case
okay
all right but the hit test there is
another element that can appear at the
bottom there
below a graphic in scenes that have a
conclusion oh that's right
that's why we
[Music]
and that has to be below the sky
is that true
um i don't know that it necessarily has
to be below that guy but right then the
thumb definitely has to be
i think above the conclusion because
it's the thumb of the graphical area not
of
oh but
no it's no no no no no it's thumbing the
whole thing right because look it made
that wider it's happy
it doesn't care it can be outside that
see
but right but but then but then
right you can hide pieces of the
of the graphics with your conclusion
right i mean yes the outer the outer
stuff is aware of the size of the
graphic
but well and what the thumb does is up
to the thumb
it doesn't have to be able to hide it i
mean that that doesn't
okay
all right so this is the most
complicated case is that a first
statement
i think so
um
yeah basically
okay who can solve this
is it possible to just make that thumb
be i mean
is there a good reason why
the standard resize knobs don't come up
for this thing
what do you mean by the standard
graphics style
um it's because we're forcing the
right it's because you can
right you can pan in here right if we
could you know you couldn't pan and
and rotate things if we just allowed the
normal behavior of graphics
um
i mean we spent a lot of time talking to
lou and brett about sort of how controls
interact with
these things and i think this was
overall the best solutions we came up
with i will say yeah this
this thing barely works
so what if there was a resize icon in
that hover
like you could only resize if you take
some user click action
yeah yeah i like that if the
if that thing only shows up when you're
hovering yeah um if i can do that i
think that would be a
decent
yeah this thing is incomprehensible as
it is right now
so you're saying you can't have knobs on
sites
for technical reasons right now
am i correct
correct
right but right in some sense it's not
that different from say manipulate of a
graphics right thing
yes
yeah go to frame
exactly although in that case with an
operator for graphics the inner graphic
has knobs
right
um
okay so what are we saying here so if
what would be the resize what would it
look like in the hover
well i say yeah one possibility is
you've got a resize button that's in the
row and if you click it you basically
get a graphics resize handles right the
graphics does the sizing like you said
but you can only enable it when you
click that well i don't know that helps
these guys because if you could enable
it
then
why not
uh you know if you can enable it and why
not have it enabled if these guys have
the technology to enable it just do it
at the drop of a hat so to speak i'm not
sure it'll be off by default so you can
pan
you don't want it to be enabled until
the user wants it
can you pan
oh you oh yes you can
oh boy
right and you can also drag things
around right oh that's probably not
going to work great on this example just
due to the the math involved
since
it's
forced to be a uh yeah regular regular
polygon
right put something like the example
below right you can drag the points
around yeah that will work
that wouldn't be obvious to me i didn't
know you could drag those points around
listen you know what
in order to make it on what happened
there well
because we show we showed it to you that
you could drag them around so you should
have known
and okay i think i think that when you
mouse into this area these points should
should uh you know back their eyes you
know bat their whatever you know they
should do something they should just
show some sign of activity
as you go into the hover
they should just flash in some way to
indicate that you can do something with
them
oh yeah we already have them uh change
color if uh
is that that little um
attached cell thing if you want to fix
the other points like yeah you fix b and
fix c now if you move a around well now
they're all fixed but
um now if you move a around the other
two stay fixed
um so we already do fine but but what
i'm saying is at the moment of hover you
should you should flash something on
those points
that's the way to indicate that they
could move
don't monetize your trust for a moment
so again like the the visual indication
should be permanently as long as your
mouse is inside or just for one or two
seconds so that you get aware of it i
thought it would just be for 300
milliseconds i see
wow that sounds like
i said that sounds like a rendering
glitch to me
yeah
i don't think it will look like a
rendering clutch
so maybe expand inside by 20
perhaps yes that will be fine i i don't
know jeremy what do you think
on mute so i think a subtle flash be
nice even you know if you could
transition too and kind of fade in out
you know something soft
be pretty nice
but you don't think people will think
it's a rendering glitch
well if it's soft if it's not jerky and
you know
too stark
if you could do it you know subtly or
you could kind of ease into it
you know kind of fade out fade in
maybe for a moment a moment bring up
some small gray text
points are movable
maybe
i think we go to experiment
um
yeah otherwise you're just not going to
get it
and if this can flash these things down
here at the same time to indicate the
connection that will be very nice
does that make sense note that those
things only appear once i mean i'm not
necessarily saying this is great ux at
the moment but right that only appears
when you click yes
and then you click again to make it go
away
when i click in here
yeah
it toggles it oh boy
i wouldn't figure that out i mean the
fact that there's no closed box here it
seems crazy to me
i think it should have a closed box
because i couldn't figure out how to get
rid of this i was wondering i thought i
would click on it oh it did when i
clicked on it again but why didn't that
happen the last time
if you were if you were a little bit off
and and yeah okay all right anyway
okay so what are we concluding about the
resize i really think the resize has to
be more obvious and i i
you know if necessary
first of all you could probably do only
have the resize come up on hover
maybe
maybe i'm not sure
it's probably possible
can you use a way to do a design even in
this case
where it won't look totally stupid not
in that position no
can the thing that comes up on hover
move to the left
and you're just saying have the resize
thing be part of that row
yeah
well i mean i guess the question is
is the resize thing coming from us or
from the operating system right because
if it comes from the operating system it
comes from it
it's an appearance element in pain
well i know that but
right i mean you can say
scroll bars is also an appearance
element but that comes from the
operating system not from uh so you
can't be sure that you know size or
style matches
well
okay i get that right but
so the question i mean i don't know does
somebody know the answer that here
brett i do not know
okay so well if it does john i'm sure we
can draw it
you know we can choose to draw it
and that seems like the right solution
to put it in that same line and then
this stuff comes up
you know to the left of it
and do you want it to
only appear when you're mousing over or
no
no have it always be there but then this
thing comes up
to the left of it
when you mouse in
yeah okay that sounds like a good
solution if assuming it's implementable
okay all right so let's check on that
and and then do that okay so can we come
back to this okay so
um
let's let me just get a sense of scope
here and let's see whether we need
jeremy
here um
so the scope we're talking about how to
style
different parts of this graphic because
i could perfectly well put in here
style of that line comma
uh it might not work on geometric step
you might have to do it on the actual
line like style
although it should work on geometric
step now that i think about it
but but a step isn't styled it's this
right it didn't work it didn't work
but it should work
right i'm
well i think maybe if you style a step
it should be like everything in that
step uh
why not
although the question is whether
whether the later steps
um yeah what do we do in later steps
yeah i don't think i don't think it
should work around the geometric step
okay all right fine
wow but then it should give a more
sentient error message yes
okay
all right so that's what that does okay
so now that's all working right now yes
but now for example if i want to as i
had wanted to do change the overall
style of the points how do i do that
um
for all the points yes
uh you do uh
underscore points and then goes to
a color
really
for for the in the
uh
hypothesis style yes there's a example
later on right so so you see how it did
circle underscore it did blank circle
through it goes to that's how you got
the purple
but that's the whole point i mean we
don't add new functionality we want to
have a clean scene that is not
additionally made complicated by styles
and separate things out okay so look if
it's going to be like this it's got to
say hypothesis style rules or something
because this is really different from
the way we do styles anywhere else
uh i mean the closest analogy would be
vertex uh label i mean i i i i i don't
think that's actually true i mean it is
different than that it's taking the
patterns on the left hand
but but the right but the basic way of
almost any style thing is foo style goes
to list of you know sub style goes to
whatever
right base style goes so
i know but well i mean i guess the
question is
does hypothesis style goes to red mean
anything or does it have to be
rules of some form
um
it's got a
um i don't think that works
well you have to read it from the from
the because you put the line the red one
i know i know yeah um yeah you if you
want to do everything green you would
have to do
okay so this is the wrong name for that
this thing yeah it's simply so this is
closer to color rules than arrays
we have anatomy styling which is more or
less allowing other balls okay notice
that it's called styling not style yes
yeah okay
and it's not an option
that's also correct
right so yeah so hypothesis yeah i'm i
mean i have no i wasn't you know i i you
know when this was shown to me for a
preliminary review i'm like okay i'm not
crazy i can't quite shoot this down but
i'm not crazy about it but that's right
the first first point is it's got to be
something like rules yeah so i think
hypothesis style rules makes perfect
sense okay but but so let's
let's just
zoom out a little bit more okay
okay i'm still confused
and i'd like an analogy for example an
anatomy for example when you're styling
skin and bones and this that nature
right don't we have a way of doing that
with an association
can i see how that works let's see oh
could you i'm not going to be starting
the a little bit down yeah okay but i
want to see it in anthony plot 3d
yeah but the examples are not to be
studying
okay well they should be in the options
section right
yes but but i think some that really fit
all
here i mean you go a little bit down oh
it's a directive it's not an option
right
but
go into scope
right but i think i mean right i think
this is different right because right
this goes in and then it has the limited
scope of whatever list it's in just like
a directive right this is a graphics
this is closer to a graphics directive
than a style option
on the left hand side with my point
where is the underbar
i i assume that if i check down a little
bit coming soon
surely this will just work if i say this
yes
all the fingers right
i should look at this i have this weird
repetitive motion injury on one of my
fingers i i need to look at anatomy
i mean but i think you know in this case
the underscore
may be sort of special
i mean i don't know that there's a lot
of
use of
yeah in associations it's pretty weird
well i mean and
right well yeah you know i i i can't
think of you know
ways that i would want to construct a
general pattern
that matched
you know specific body parts in some way
right and
i mean if you literally do like
alternatives here will it work i mean is
this actually a pattern or is or is
blank just you know a sort of fake
syntax
i mean obviously it can't be a
completely general pattern but you know
how do i find it michael just just how
do i find the bones in that and well
let's see if i just type it in i think
just yeah the hand and the letter
okay
carpet
but okay so then i say entity list of
this is that right
that would be nice but i suspect not
because it doesn't look like it's an
entity class it doesn't look like uh
yeah
same it's a list of bones of the left
hand
or
maybe there you needed a different
assumption
well these are some bugs
in this how do i get
do do you have any senses probably some
property but i don't know what it would
be called
why the heck isn't that auto completing
that's another bug
dorothy that's for you
okay thanks
okay so if i say
but what what do i
what bones
does it say bones somewhere here yeah
like seventh line two-thirds the way
across
just says bones yep
okay i just want to solve
this are no bones in the left-hand
appearance okay go down until you see
functional categories
go over
past bone count
that you know it's crazy though included
bones
it's crazy that these things don't
that you don't know what to type from
this
okay but then we have to recursively
bonify this yes
or are these
i mean set of sounds more like an entity
list you know type thing do you need to
map entity list across disks or do you
need
to this seems like a a
okay
okay so now what i presumably want to
say is i take one of these the left i
wonder if i know what which one is it
which part is the finger it's up there
right
what's happening
those are the three
right the phalanges and the systemoids
right the carpal and metacarpal are or
the wrist
no i understand that's back down here
right by this point the hand has ended
in its fingers from here on out is that
right
right
which i believe are the phalanges and
this
sesamoid
okay so here if i go like this
and i say in here
just don't
i don't know what the anybody know the
precedence
well
put parens around it for good measure
ah where are they
yeah i don't think it's yeah you know an
actual pattern it's just underscore is
special
we should i think so fix that cheat yeah
okay okay separate issue all right let's
go back over here
okay even though i really want to debug
my hand based on this um
okay never mind um
boy i hadn't even thought of that yeah
it's got all that data
um
okay
so
the thing that i'd like to be able to do
where's the conclusion relative to
i mean in other words
isn't aren't these just i mean what if i
want to color the third step in orange
and so on how do i do that
that's not doable from this is it
now i don't understand the difference
between hypothesis that's this whole
thing here yeah the styling of this
whole thing it's the styling of elements
in this whole thing here
yep
yep
and i have to say
that you know i would like to see some
plot themes here because as far as
there's exactly the goal of the whole
thing yeah
first effort
well where do you put the plot themes
into hypothesis style as a string
now the whole thing would one day have a
blood seam option but they must be
somehow implemented and materialized and
they cannot be done through
adding locally inside the actual scene
i see
okay but i mean the point is
what we're trying to do and each
individual object in here is is
trivially modifiable yeah right so we
can say you know whatever we want to say
dotted
red oops not like that
see this is
yeah it shouldn't just pink like that
anyway okay so there we have a nice it's
no different than graphics yeah but he
doesn't like hidden graphics either so
why is that not red
um
i'm color blind i don't know um so what
uh
yeah what what happened
mishandling style if you put directive
around dotted in red well i understand
that but it's it's mishandling it right
well
sure but let's let's just diagnose that
it's
no there's some deeper issue well so the
uh i think the style might uh might be
ignoring the edge form so it might have
like a gray it might be
doing red over a gray edge form
there's a bug yeah you gotta fix it yeah
okay
be that as it may
um
and i could say like for example
presumably i can say this i was gonna
say can you try thickened dot and dotted
didn't seem to work maybe it did i don't
know thick thickness
0.1
that worked
[Laughter]
okay are you sure etai
um pretty sure
okay so now the issue here is that what
you want to do is bank style all the
lines
for example yeah
but i don't even see the points for
example here i haven't a clue how you
like like i wanted to draw one of these
without labels on the points how do i do
that
um
yes
this is what we are talking about
because the points are not explicitly
there they are something special yeah
well so what this is like is a vertex
style function
vertex shape function
rather
right it's the analog of that because
the vertices aren't really there but
they have some styling
what do you mean the vertices aren't
really there
well i mean the vertices you don't even
know where they are coordinate wise
it's an overlay given the graph the
rendering of vertices is a subsequent
act
right but
but
okay well i i'm not sure what point
you're trying to make i mean here you
have you've named three points a b and c
and then you get three style points
the point i'm trying to make is that
just like a graph
is a representation that implicitly
specifies a bunch of things and then it
is rendered the same is true here you're
implicitly specifying this geometric
scene and then it is rendered
so the analogy
okay except that you ask for an instance
of this of the scene but sure
right okay fair enough which is
i mean okay let's just pull this analogy
a little bit further
we don't have an instance of a graph we
could
right but it's the same type of thing a
graph defines certain constraints
and then our graph layout
automatically instances the graph in
effect
true statement
no
so it seems to me there's a close
analogy between this and the instancing
of graphs
exactly no no no no there isn't because
this
actually literally contains
the thing right and you can do random
instance of 10 and get 10 different
instances that all look quite well i
mean it raises the interesting question
of should you be able to do random
instance of a graph
and get 10 different layouts
because each layout has a certain i mean
it's not unique by any means
sure except well i mean certainly all
the current graph layouts we have are
deterministic
i mean if you really wanted to do that i
mean you can specify vertex coordinates
and
it's just uh
getting
us a random result i feel like there's
somehow a difference like a graph
always exists otherwise you couldn't
even write it down you can't write down
an incorrect graph then it isn't the
cost anymore
right but you could talk about random
embeddings
yes of course right it's the embedding
not the cause
well it's the same thing here i mean
it's the embedding as in the actual
coordinate values of the points are
the constraint of what's connected to
what and how
is independently determined
then there is an embedding that is what
the random instance gives you
but the
positions actually matter here they
don't matter in grass yeah it feels
different to me it's a little different
right i admit it's a little different
but in terms of this design
let me see okay let me just understand
your proposed design has just these two
hypothesis styles and um
conclusion
styles right and and for example with
conclusion style right if you use fine
geometric conjectures to add
style you know to add conclusions
then you don't even know what the
conclusions are
you don't even have
you know conclusions in there before you
you know to wrap anything around which
is why conclusion style is useful
okay but the thing i want to know is
i i just wanted and i i needed this in
practice okay and i did a total hacker
hackalola to to achieve this
i just wanted that picture without it i
just want that picture without the abc
okay so tell me how i do that
um
you'd have to go
uh
if you're using the hypothesis you
already lost the game
because this has got to be easy people
are making a geometric construction they
just want a show
as i did for something i just want to
show the construction i don't want to
say it's an abc construction
um
do you uh
want the the little discs around them
gone too
i want to be able to style them my own
way
ah then that's
that is uh eventually going to be one of
our plot themes but that's not available
yet
okay but you any plot theme has to be
achievable by direct code
right i think this would be uh
how would it be achieved
oh yeah i'm going to make a different
suggestion
could you do something try try something
like th like the following do
blank point goes to
uh white
oh no well no no no no no no
goes to opacity of zero yeah that's not
gonna work
you wait and see it's gonna leave a big
space there yeah well
which is well if you'd actually heard my
whole suggestion it would have been
you know font color goes to opacity of
zero
well okay that worked i admit that that
worked
but that's utterly obscure but i feel
like the problem here is actually the
uppercase point is misused because the
first arguments in geometric scene abc
are not really uppercase points they're
lowercase points right so i've got a
suggestion guys
i think what should happen here
is this should be called
uh
you know an option geometrics
you know scene
style or styling or something and it
should just be a freaking association
and it should just say points are styled
this way
you know point style arrow blah you know
line blah blah you've got all kinds of
freedom and you just basically you know
describe it as you want to describe it
so you can say
point labels arrow true point labels
arrow false
you can say
you have a lot much number of magic
strings
that's what i'm suggesting well you
wouldn't that wouldn't uh
well part of uh part of the thing here
sometimes you don't want all triangles
to look the same but you also don't want
to have to put style in the uh
in the second argument like a lot of
that you want to post process them by
having triangles which match a
particular pattern
have a particular form right but you can
look at the strings
oh yes you can yes you can you just say
something like
uh style patterns or something arrow and
then you do your triangles but this is a
fake
as you've just admitted
right and all these fakes are gonna you
know blow up on our face
right underscore point is not doing pure
pattern matching
true statement
uh that's the one exception that's the
one exception point yes
because
i love you know points yes i understand
so
but but the association would work but
we would also allow in the left-hand
side in addition to magic strings
expert seed elements of the scene
like a certain line i want to be read
but i don't want to dirty the second
argument
i mean i guess the weird thing with the
point there
is that it's in hypothesis style but a b
and c aren't in the hypotheses
yeah well they show up with the line if
you did stop if you did line of list of
style of a red comma the endless that
would work
really
yeah
what
yeah what did you just say
i said have steve steven type that in
if you if you so you have like style
line
red if you just put that style
just around the a
in the first step oh come on okay i want
to put down the speed yeah
no idea no no no no no i know i know
i don't think that would work
but
i think that would work
interestingly the a and b got lost here
they're still covered by the point goes
to opacity zero right
right so uh the inner ones always be
against the other ones yes the uh and
rappers always went over options
now the more interesting question is can
you do something like style of b font
color goes to opacity of zero to just
make the label disappear and and yeah
that was a big point
well that's a hack
okay whatever
let's go to an earlier step
oh
that is so freaking weird it's because
it didn't need the early later ones yet
oh but i understand that's on step two
it kind of saw the color
in step one and
remember right well things are additive
right it's always happening so so
derek only added the circles and didn't
change anything then you added this
triangle above it and that triangle had
a new opinion about the color of b so it
overrode
okay look it's nice functionality if
anybody could ever figure it out
is this documented at all
this incredible weirdness here
if i go looking for that documentation
will i find it
i think so
and geometric c nice yeah the
geometric scene documentation is pretty
long but i'm pretty sure that that's
because people understand the
documentation and that that's what it
means
um
i would just do a search for style
because i have no idea yeah it's there
the display can be specified using style
that doesn't tell me this
that there's this extra hack for points
doesn't tell me that in the slightest
bit
uh well is it one of the list of things
that's listed under
objects
so what
well if it's an object then and objects
can be wrapped nope nope
so it's so but we lose the game
yep
there's a point that would be there we
wouldn't even know what to find
yeah i know i know so it's going to be
so so there's a there's a documentation
inadequacy here
yes
okay
i mean
i would never have guessed that that
would work
all right so let's come back to this
i that's just crazy in my view
no disagreement point was not the one we
had mostly in mind here right
right but if you do circle through of
underscore comma a goes to purple
okay i mean that's nice
right i mean maybe
what we need here is to just add you
know a couple of magic strings like
maybe point is a magic string and we
just document it i think or or that's
the same points we should even have
magic right hand sides
okay guys guys
uh
look let's
do something like this okay we just have
a geometric steam scene styling
and then a big long association which we
can document we can have special cases
we can have all kinds of things and
style patterns the other stylings are
not options
what's that is that the other stylings
are not options
we have anatomy styling and geostyle so
you're you're saying
what would be the right name for this
it's not like color rules
i mean i i don't
why does this have to be an association
i think this would be better as a list
of rules
that right i mean th this has you know
in the language of
of of you know
style options this has
list like inheritance not association
like inheritance
this is this is better as a list of
rules
well okay look you've got several
different things
you want to say okay my prediction is
that there are just tons and you've
already admitted this there are tons of
weird cases that you want to switch on
and off
that you were saying well we'll do it
with plot themes but i don't believe in
that there needs to be an explicit way
to do it
no no no i think misunderstanding every
plot theme must somehow rely on such
technology
okay this is a precursor to plot things
yes
language of things that plot themes will
rely on
right and do its job
right and the only thing i'm disputing
is is that this should be an association
i'm saying this should be a list of
rules which can be patterns or magic
strings which can be documented
i mean
yeah we're not using
the association functionality at all so
yes i agree with that all right okay
fair point but now you've got a
different issue which is
they occur in the hypotheses they occur
in the conclusions
so the conclusion
to me the right thing to do will be to
have this list of rules
and maybe to have the possibility of
having a double because i can imagine
that i just want to switch all my points
you know to be dots rather than the
circles
or something yeah i don't want to have
to separately do that for hypothesis and
conclusions
so i'm wondering if there's a way to get
either inside or outside and that could
be an association play so the conclusion
styling is
is fundamentally different from this the
conclusion styling is much more narrow
in scope uh for
technical reasons
uh and i love the phrase for technical
reasoning yeah i mean i was not aware of
this why is it much more limited in
scope well because i mean that if you
look at the actual conclusion style um
example i forget where they are
somewhere down here uh that's where you
can actually
you just say red and it'll highlight
things in red so
um okay you you are just making the case
even more strongly that we just want an
association or a list with magic strings
right and then conclude right so and
then conclusions uh this becomes
conclusion style
and that that's as a magic string as a
magic string yes i i i i agree with that
that's fabulous i agree
okay so that then becomes an overlay
style for conclusions
yes right and and i think we call this
geometric style rules and
geometrics well what no it's not really
what you're doing your magic scene
uh well that's too many words
i like i kind of like geometric style
rules or
appearances
yeah
no because we've used that to generic i
mean unless we want to i don't know can
we reuse appearance rules
i feel like this is different right
because appearance rules is really about
what should and should not appear
right
in addition to sort of how it looks
and how it's more if
yeah
um
but maybe jim
yeah no
geometric styling rules
that's fine
i mean by the way does it have to be an
option or can it be an argument
it's gonna be uh
right because because uh right uh we've
since said right since you can have two
or three arguments
yeah
okay geometric styling rule seems okay
now the question is what
and so here you can just put in all
kinds of stuff like
um
you know
point star i mean i i would do things
like
uh
you know styling patterns
blah blah blah
then i would say things like um
what would be an example of the blah
blah blah
just so that's like the stuff we
originally have up there this thing here
okay
good
so that's
including expedited ones like line a b
yeah yeah yeah yeah styling patterns is
just the
the magic word for what we already know
okay good
all right so then we've got
a minus blank point because yeah exactly
point style
we won't necessarily uh
document that but
and then there we have now also magic
keys on the right hand side
well i think there should be a point
styling function
that is just like a vertex shape
function where you just give it the
coordinates and the name and the
coordinates just like vertex shape
function and it just tells you what to
render yeah that's it's probably not
going to make it into 13 one but they've
been
that's definitely been on our radar to
have something like this
my on the only point i will raise was
that that won't allow you to easily turn
off the labels right because i know
we're going to oh i see i mean
it would allow you to easily turn off
the appearance entirely by making it you
know nothing
but you you wouldn't be able to right so
i don't think that's enough i don't
think that's enough just like it isn't
for vertices so i think we want
um
uh
maybe finally
arrow true false automatic you know yes
on non-automatic the usual stuff
non-automatic or
you know whatever you do in um
and we should use we can use the same
exact conventions as we do for graphs
where you can have
a list of pattern rules potentially
might want a couple more like you wanted
a little bit to the right or something
like this right so but but you can just
put in
whatever tweakings you want yeah
and then then there's also uh conclusion
styling
concussion style
arrow
and that will just be like a red or
green
why would i assume so yes
um
and right and and if in some in the
future we come up with some more ornate
santa syntax to handle some more ornate
situation
well then we just document that what if
if the arises
i think that here
i mean
where did i just see this oh my gosh
where
what was i just reviewing oh molecules
right where where again unlike graphs
they do a centered a placed in the
center
name for their this is sulfur or
something
michael you know what i'm talking about
i think so
so that's directly analogous to this
whereas
in a plot
vertex labels
represents the off you know by default
the label is off
to the side of the vertex
whereas in chemistry and i forget the
option name in chemistry like here the
vertex label is is there not off to the
side
right
although i claim that it would be
reasonable to have an option for this
where it is off to the side
for geometric scene yeah definitely no
we have discussions yeah
so it'd be good to have that sort of
agree with the way that chemistry is
doing it
um
all right what else do we have to figure
out here i mean we haven't figured out
all these names but i think you guys
need to iterate on that right yeah i
mean i assume that's going to be uh just
adding to that
every
i think so everything you can think of i
mean
um
okay what else do we have to figure out
here i think i was basically yeah yeah
and i
um that that this was just uh just
amusement
yeah it's just amusement yeah
i mean this is this is why you want the
the post overlay so yeah
um
okay
anything else
no i think we're done yeah that's cool
could you uh send this to me
yes yeah this replied to the uh you know
you got the
damn god knows where that is okay i see
it
um oops
um
oh
okay
all right
um
there it goes
okay
um
good stuff all right thank you